und wenn ja wo leute hey hier sieht eure
mal waren und bekommt zu einem neuen
adventskalender aus park video heute mit
zohan and only you die adventskalender
von harry potter ihr habt gesehen was
das für eine arbeit war diesen advent
kann hut zu bekommen ich musste nach
england dafür es war auch eine super
schöne reise und ich bin so happy dass
ich das gemacht habe
england und london und so schön und auf
jeden fall sehr empfehlenswert aber
jetzt geht es natürlich um dieses baby
der adventskalender von harry potter der
wird nur bei boots verkauf das ist ein
drogerie laden in england und der wurde
nicht online versendet nach deutschland
und dann hat man quasi nur in england
bekommen korrigiert mich falls ich
falsch liege also das waren meine
erfahrungen und wenn das noch nicht
genug ist ich habe ein sehr sehr großes
gewinnspiel am ende also bleibt dran und
jetzt packen wir ihn aus bin
ungeschminkt weil ich hoffe das war
beatty artikel drin sind die ich auch
gleich anwenden kann
wie beim shopping queen adventskalender
werden wir uns hier gleich dazu ein
bisschen schminken ich bin ich freue
mich einfach glücklich
[Applaus]
eigentlich sind auch gerne selber sei
das geländer benutzt aber also kommt ich
muss ihn euch zeigen oder einen
disclaimer
ich habe den in meinem handgepäck dabei
gehabt und weil der flüssigkeiten drin
sind mussten wir den einmal ich hab's
nicht gemacht zum glück
wir mussten den einmal auspacken alles
rausholen in so eine durchsichtige tüte
packen und dann wieder alles reinpacken
deswegen wird wahrscheinlich die
reihenfolge der produkte falsch seien
aber am ende sind seit die gleichen
produkte
leider war das unvermeidbar aber ich
habe es ja zum glück noch nicht gesehen
darum hat sich jemand anderes gekümmert
ich weiß sehr happy dass ich die nicht
anschauen musste man hat halt ein
bisschen geblutet dabei ganz ehrlich ist
so mächtig und türen also was steckt ein
türchen nummer 1 eingreifen dollar
gleich mit rot und goldenen pigmenten
ich so judith pohl und dieses moskau
dazu das ist das teilt jetzt nicht
wusste ich bin im haus griffen doch ich
habe zwei oder drei mal den test gemacht
ich bin ein größten dorf türchen nummer
zwei ich sterbe gerade einfach dem
zauberstab aussieht ist auch überhaupt
nicht kitschig ist stylisch gehalten in
diesem rot gold alles fühlt sich richtig
wertig an wenn man sich damit schmiegen
typische nummer drei
sind es wieder griffen dort griffen dort
bade bombe uhr lief sehr sehr gut
also damit kriegen sie einen aus haiti
in kombination mit harry potter sorry
das ist das einfach gemein türchen
nummer vier
ich glaube die farben sind immer nach
den häusern sortiert und dadurch dass es
falsch einsortiert wurde passen jetzt
die farben auf den zahlen und die häuser
nicht ganz ist haben sich in nummer vier
haben wir einen schlimmeren lippenstift
in grün oder was ist ein einbruch als
segen glaube es nur lippborg crazy es
ist nur einem pflegestift für die lippen
mit ganz wenig farbe aber dadurch kriegt
man so blaue lippen obwohl ich weiß
nicht ob man da nicht einfach
ausgedörrte transferieren würde aber nee
ist eigentlich ist ist schön ist schön
leute mit türchen nummer fünf eine harte
partie
mein gott jetzt ich find's ganz cool
wenn man zum beispiel selber in griffen
dort drinnen so eine freundin hat die in
hasselbach drin ist dann kann man jedes
geschenk man dann ist das total die süße
überraschung der welt kalender hat
übrigens 25 pfund gekostet das sind
ungefähr 30 euro und ich habe die
vermutung dass man auch ungefähr den
wert bekommen türchen nummer 6 hier
haben wir ein paar schöne pässe waren
drauf türchen nummer 7
also man kriegt jetzt halt alles doppelt
und dreifach weil es die häuser sich um
ein es ist so ironisch dass ich jetzt
einfach nicht greifen kann werdet
erfahren warum
glaub ich krieg den sie nicht aus ich
habe den goldenen schnitts gefahren 50
punkte für bissendorf baden formen die
aussieht wie der goldene spatz tische
nummer 8 und wir haben
die auswahl ist ein bisschen monotonen
gerade
ich hoffe dass da noch mehr kommt
endlich 8 ist ein blauer pflegestift
natürlich für reamonn kirchen nummer 9
sprintet es seien etwa eines leser in
badeborn eine grüne leserin bade ich hab
diese folie darum dass man immer so
schwer abdi riecht auch gut er ist jetzt
am besten am ende haben sie alle den
gleichen durch nummer 10 steht kommt er
jetzt noch nagellack das ist eine schöne
farbe blau raven klage lag wo es
sinnvoll die perfekten weihnachts farben
mein gott der raven klo nagellack zu
blau und solider glitzerte rinn very
pretty bin gespannt was für die qualität
das hat sich sehr sehr flüssig aus
türchen nummer elf hat sich der shopping
queen adventskalender abgesprochen ein
rot gold hogwarts schlüsselanhänger
ich meine bei shopping fand es unnötig
den werde ich mir safe und einen
schlüsselbund machen ja für dessen cent
und hübsches harry potter kommen harry
potter kann toilettenpapier bedrucken
also das franchise nicht harry potter
und wir würden es uns kaufen wirklich
jetzt schon harry potter toilettenpapier
das frage ich eigentlich natürlich wird
es geben wir sind in der hälfte
angekommen
es sieht aus wie seine passion slammerin
badezeug also dieses all das design ist
wirklich der hammer und zur
weihnachtszeit wenn ich eh immer so ein
harry potter stimmung wenn ich mir jetzt
vorstelle dass ich mir so in die wanne
[Musik]
das was großes kino
raven klamotten array lohan cream am 3
ich will aber die griffen dort haben 14
hauser ist immer auch ein bisschen
retten severin handcreme 15 glücklich
havelpark handcreme warum drückt man
drei tage hintereinander handcreme 16
gräfendorf handcreme ja gibt machen wir
es aber aus wenn ich jetzt aber komisch
warum macht man dann vier tage
hintereinander handcreme rhein vor
gericht schön
die hat etwas ganz frisches zitronige ja
nie werde ich auf jeden fall benutzen
und immer ganz stolz aus meiner
handtasche rausholen dann irgendwelche
harry potter fans die mir sind so ich
benutze mal meine hände sind wieder so
trocken
ich brauche auf jeden fall was für
männer griffen der handcreme 8 sorry die
kann man nur in england kaufen
das werde nicht budget schade oder wenn
sie alles gleich persönlich glaube sie
haben aber alles vielleicht animiert dom
am 17
was haben wir oder schafe paar fans von
krassen farben so dass grün und so das
werde ich dort meine bade war das stimmt
und wenn man gäste darf und sage ich ja
neben dir was von denen harry potter
band sind die nummer 18 im typischen 18
haben wir havelpark nagellack also das
sind wirklich schöne farben ist haben
die glück gehabt
die häuser so schöne farben haben
clayton klar bades ich habe es aber
nicht so hoch pigmentiert sieht aus wie
normale seife sieht aber auch ein
bisschen aus wie die probleme größe die
man im hotels kriegt so sieht es aus ist
hier das was immer so im badezimmer
steht man sich jeden tag in die tasche
einfach würde ich niemals machen da mach
ich habe die nummer 20
jetzt kommen die meinen wir einfach die
nägel mit allen farben an
das grün ist wunderschön das ist
wirklich bio ev mit dem glitzert ist sie
da rein machen hat das so richtig ist
nicht so einfach grün sondern es hat so
einfach so ein sehr groß ist wie wenn du
die farben zum beispiel so blau und gelb
kombiniert oder grün und rot dann hast
du halt richtige christmas tree hill
oder rot und gelb kannst du auch
kombinieren grünen nicht so sehr schön
21 da es mein gryffindor badezeug ist es
meine collection complete aber es auch
blöd sobald man einst benutzt die
collection nicht mehr kommen klingt es
gibt auch nur richtig cool auch wenn du
alle häuser haus 22 tägigen blockade
kugel
sie sieht aber auch ein bisschen aus wie
ein klub stein mit dem bau soll ihn so
typischen bereichs land natürlich musst
du das nachkommen
die gruppendritten pflege und natürlich
die besten gut eignet sich für den
lippenpflege besser als blaue ja das
gibt's dann richtig schön leicht einen
roten touch waren auch sehr wenig mehr
ist ein ganz also schaut euch das an das
ist ja nichts wirklich gar nichts hier
drin ja und jetzt sind wir schon beim
letzten türchen angekommen
türchen 24
das haben wir hier ja okay eine augen
ist das für den beauty sleep oh mein
gott und da ist harry potter insel
vorlaufes fast ohne das kann man sich
bei akuten tv mit dem code anschauen ich
glaube also prime now hat den film auch
gerade aber ansonsten dankeschön dem
gucke ich mir jetzt erst mal gleich an
okay ich habe auf jeden fall ihr kennt
mich ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen enttäuscht ich meine ich bin
ungeschminkt weil ich dachte dass so ein
bisschen mehr drin sein wird ist ja
nicht deren schuld sie haben das jetzt
nie so wirklich als beauty
adventskalender verkauft aber dadurch
dass bei putz und so war dachte ich so
dass ich meine schade über seine griffen
bei shadow palette hätte ich mich echt
gefreut glaubt die gab es dort aber zu
kaufen nur weil ich dachte das ist so in
so einem beauty adventskalender auch
drin sein wird wollte ich nicht extra
holen das ist die ausbeute
was sagt ihr es sind ja immer selbst das
so für jedes haus gibt es fünf sachen
ist schon cool ich bin ein bisschen
enttäuscht wisst ihr warum das konzept
mit denen häusern ist eigentlich ganz
kugel aber dadurch bekommt man halt
alles in allen häusern indem man zum
beispiel auch nicht mal ist oder die
häuser die man nicht mag oder ihr wisst
was ich meine
dann kommt man halt immer so zu 4 juli
wäre es gewesen wenn man sich an bands
kalender nach häusern halt kaufen
kreisels und griffen dort wenz kalender
gibt oder ein havelpark dann kannst du
dann mit richtig was anfangen ich meinem
erkauft man sich ja auch mal nach dem
haus in dem man ins oder einfach
irgendwie mehr von solchen neutralen
harry potter produkten und nicht nur die
häuser
also es ist ja der hogwarts
adventskalender aber trotzdem vielleicht
so ein paar sachen die nicht nach
hausgemacht sind zum beispiel die
lippenpflege man sich sparen können
oder wer braucht ihr handcreme aber
trotzdem also ich will ganz ich will gar
nicht dass es so meckern auf hohem
niveau gerade ich freue mich halt übels
über die daten vor allem wirklich weil
ich will es gleich ins badezimmer
stellen werde und mich so ein arsch
träumen das set von harry potter
badezeug steht oder auch die badekugeln
das finde ich richtig cool am ende kann
man einfach seine freunde auch eine
überraschung machen indem man halt eine
handcreme schenk und dazu passenden
nagellack und passenden links und das
fahrzeug
wenn man das abgeben und dann machst du
so ein schönes paket und sagt hier du
bist jetzt lehrerin aber wenn man so ein
adventskalender möchte man ja eigentlich
in sachen kommen wir jetzt zum
heftigsten gewinnspiel was ich jemals
jemals machen werde
also es gibt eine kleine
hintergrundstory dazu kelly und ich
haben uns tipps geholt für das neue
theaterstück im märz 2020 harry potter
und das verwunschene kind das was es
schon in london new york und so gilt
kommt jetzt auch nach deutschland
vor ungefähr drei jahren in london
gesehen dieses jahr haben wir es ja in
new york gesehen und wir hatten uns die
tickets schon lange vor new york geholt
also sobald sie rauskam haben wir uns
nie bestellt jetzt ist es so dass wir
eingeladen wurden und sich anzuschauen
hammer für kelly und milch ist das
wirklich das allergrößte dass wir harry
potters also arbeiten dort eingeladen
werden nur jetzt habe ich diese decke
und ich kann es mir nicht noch mal in
deutschen angucken also das reicht nicht
ich dann habe ich mich zum dritten mal
angeschaut sagt ist auch gut und
deswegen verlor sich die tickets an euch
und es sind keine ganz normalen tickets
kelly und ich habe richtig tief in die
tasche
getroffen weil wir das so sehr wollte es
sind tickets in der preisklasse 1 in der
zweiten reihe leute diese tickets waren
so arch teuer ich glaube ich habe fast
600 euro für die tickets bezahlt und ich
möchte sie an euch verlosen weil ich
glaube dass ich euch eine freude damit
machen kann und ich habe noch nie so
richtig was von mir selbst verlost ich
dachte dass es mal zeit irgendwie ist es
kurz vor weihnachten und ich bin ich
freue mich jetzt einfach schon wie diese
person die diese tickets gewinnen wird
weil deshalb so eine krasse chance ist
ihr könnt es sogar noch vor der premiere
alles was sie dafür tun wird ist auf
instagram rüber zu gehen und das foto wo
ich das passte zu kommentieren eine
person zu verlinken also ist die person
verlinken mit der ihr das schauen wollte
müsste alt genug seien um dahin fahren
zu können wenn er zum beispiel nicht aus
hamburg kommt oder so wenn ihr noch
jünger seid dann habt ihr vielleicht
mami die ihr mitbringen könnt aber ihr
müsst sie auf instagram verlinken unter
dem pos und dann schreiben warum ihr
denn die person mitnehmen wollte nach
hamburg harry potter oder verrückte kind
anzuschauen ich kann euch sagen ich
empfehle es jedem ich habe das jetzt
nicht ohne grund schon zum zweiten mal
geschaut und ich freue mich schon
tierisch tierisch aus dritte mal auf
deutsch ja ich habe sogar einen zweiten
platz für die leute was einige sein
werden die die tickets nicht gewinnen
hab euch einen zweiten advents kalender
mitgebracht seht ihr uns erst noch
geschlossen
gleiche prozedur wie bei den tickets
geht auch instagram like das bild mit
dem adventskalender folgt mir auf
instagram es mal war nachhaltig dort und
hier postet die auch weh mir diesen
adventskalender schenken wollen das
heißt wenn ihr ihn selber jetzt
unbedingt haben wollte obwohl ihr schon
inhalt gesehen habt könnt ihr eine
freundin fragen ob sie euch nach verlegt
aber ja die verlinkte person unter dem
instagram post gewinnt das also verlinkt
niemanden der das ding nicht haben will
das wäre eine verschwendung verlinkt
wirklich eine person wo ihr glaubt dass
es eine freude bereiten würde ich weiß
ist ein bisschen unfair aber bei
adventskalendern gibt es ja meistens um
das beschenken von einem adventskalender
deswegen dachte ich gewinnt ihr für
jemanden anderen kommen sagt man jetzt
mal bitte wie super nett ich bin hallo
und ach so und wenn ihr es für jemand
anderes ermöglicht dann könnt ihr euch
den inhalt ja auch teilen ich meine da
ist ja genug drin
und jetzt möchte ich mal ein ganz
schweres dank gehört weil ich hätte auch
noch einkaufen könnten dann dachte ich
so nicht nur noch ein zweiter unfall
losgehen wie nett ist es denn wenn man
so schwer an den adventskalender
rankommt ihr habt zeit
drei tage lang hier steht ein datum und
dann verstehe ich ganz schnell an die
person die über nacht und leute geiler
kannst das ist mein peak
teilnahmebedingungen sind natürlich in
der video beschreibung auch noch mal
verlinkt das auch meinen instagram
account da könnt ihr dann rauf gehen
ich freue mich drauf eigentlich liebt
und ja ich werde jetzt noch einen
anderen adventskalender auspacken um
mein gott ich habe noch ein wenig
unbedingt jetzt auspacken kann
bis dann bis zum nächsten mal bis zum
nächsten video ab